Marvel has made a collection of films
that even had I not been a part of these
movies had I said no to these movies it
would have been the biggest mistake of
my life I consider these movies what
Star Wars was to me all that being said
look obviously I'm looking at do stuff
beyond the role but but but it at the
end of the day I really look at it as a
real blessing and and and it was at one
point in my life something that I was
really apprehensive about and in
retrospect I can say with complete
confidence it was the best decision I've
ever made even if even if you know just
for these idiots for the friendships I
made just for the friendships even if
these movies sucked and you know my
career was tanked because of
pigeon-holed just to be friends with
these morons I how hard was it when you
first read that scene and you're like
man I have to basically my best friend
is in the movie is about to be dead
first of all the scene was I'd only ever
read it for sure it might have been
written but I never read it they told me
about it and we shot it and it's very
different that's in the movie now it's a
scene we Bri shot because it's much more
complicated seeing that that's in an end
game now there is an attack Thanos had
some ship or something and a bunch of
weird aliens or run around and made it
too complicated so what they did is we
shot the scene still with the same kind
of idea but now we're just fighting each
other to go commit suicide again so
soulstone and that was a let me shot
that not that long ago it's only six
months ago and it said that's a tough it
was a tough scene for both of us to
shoot weird is all hell two people
trying to hurt each other so they can go
try to you know commit suicide but um
she's just trying to bring Clint back to
his wife can't talk about it
Renard is gonna say you and ScarJo that
was I like the Hulk and Thor
language got it there's a child right
here
right there am I about this this
is insane I can't believe that happened
yeah it's a good question and it's a
good question that's one of those things
where that's a good question there's
probably a lot of answers our answer was
so amazing because I want to answer that
we you're we're gonna would you if she
asked it on Twitter were you answer it
on Twitter later yeah sure maybe Coco
maybe I'll get back to you on that one
hit me
America's ass yeah premier Premier when
you had no clothes on so while we missed
Hawkeye and infinity war a little bit no
I was smart I didn't turn to ashes yeah
I was hanging out man
it was scary you're bad people and I was
pissed off I guess you know the only saw
for a minute it's literally effect for
two minutes of the movie and then I had
to go do something else save the world
no just I don't know what I was doing
but
something I think whether I just
supposed to try to kill myself on the
movie and then Scarlett got in the way
you know oh shoot I thought that once
that night erect me I've seen it once hi
everyone its Charlie's we had our first
Avengers end game Marvel phase for
comic-con panel it's the middle of
convention season obviously the next big
one is gonna be Comic Con later and then
d23 after that so in addition to the
really cool stuff and deleted scenes
that they talked about during this panel
which I'll break down in a second so
also gonna be revealing the Marvel phase
forge schedule or at least some of it
during Comic Con in a couple weeks and
then after that Indy 23 will learn about
even more that I'll be doing videos for
everything so be sure to subscribe if
you're brand new to the channel we're
doing a new round of the IMAX ticket
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave an Avengers
or Spider Man comment on the video I'll
name a new winner at the end of this
love those Captain America f-bombs just
drops one then immediately realizes that
he's sitting in front of a crowd of
children Don Cheadle can't believe it
just walks right off a stage one of the
other really cool reveals here too is
that Chris Evans is like yeah I'm
definitely coming back outside the role
of Captain America that's just the
teasers that the Russos were dropping
before Avengers end game come out like
Chris Evans isn't quite done with Marvel
even if Captain America is really old
man right now so just breaking this down
and order Chris Evans talked about how
he turned down the role of Captain
America twice before he accepted and
signed his first contract with Marvel
Studios that was before they started
making the first Captain America movie
he spends a couple minutes making friend
of those other two they're all really
good friends they're like a family in
real life now like the Avengers are
family within the context of the movies
but the actors have become a family in
the last 10 years so when he says he's
coming back to Marvel to do stuff beyond
the role of Captain America he's mostly
talking about the Marvel phase 4 stuff
directing and doing stuff behind the
camera because while most people know
him for the roles that he's played he's
also been a director for a long time -
working on really small indie movies
between the really big Marvel movies
that he's been doing the last 10 years
they haven't said exactly which project
he'll be working out but I expected as
something to do with those Avengers
spin-off TV series they're doing for the
Disney Plus streaming service so we'll
probably learn more about that by the
time we get to d23 in August that's
about the month after comic-con the
other really big reveal is Hawkeye
talking about this giant extended
sequence that they
completely changed on form eared just is
really huge deleted scene where Thanos
was originally supposed to come attack
them when they came to get the soul
stone I'm assuming it was the version of
fan O's from 2014 because they were all
there in 2014 with nebula and war
machine while they were getting the
Power Stone
then Black Widow and Hawkeye just
literally took off in the guardianship
and flew through space to Vermeer they
didn't travel through time when they
went to voor Mir because they were
already before Thanos came in 2018 to
get the soul stone that's all they
needed to do and because they were in
2014 already they beat him by about four
years the battle that he describes as
Stannis coming down with the outriders
because he talks about really weird
villains that he didn't know about and
he knew about the Black Order so I'm
assuming it was not the Black Order that
came to voir Mir with Thanos
in the original version of events but if
you remember the other part of the
latest scene that he talks about was
when Hawkeye was trying to kill himself
to sacrifice himself for the soul stone
because his family was dead it was his
inspiration for becoming Ronin why he
went so hardcore he was just ready to
die himself he was doing everything he
could to try and throw himself on his
sword without doing it literally until
the opportunity presented itself when
they got to war Mir and learn what it
took to obtain the soul stone oh okay
I've been trying to do this for the last
couple of years since I lost my family
for whatever reason like jeremy renner
says late in the game they changed that
scene and it wound up being Black Widow
to sacrifice herself I think it probably
would have been better if Hawkeye would
have sacrificed himself and they do a
Disney Plus Hawkeye series where he
trains Kate Bishop after the events of
the snap then when she learns after
Avengers endgame that Hawkeye died on
for Mir she takes the mantle of Hawkeye
and joins the Young Avengers during
Marvel phase four Raina the Black Widow
movie seems like it's taking place after
the events of Captain America Civil War
but before the events of Avengers
infinity war in the snap that'll be part
of Marvel's big comic-con Hall H panel
they actually have footage of the Black
Widow movie that they can show off in
Hall H in a couple weeks I thought it
was kind of funny the Don Cheadle said
that he didn't know Iron Man was
supposed to die at the end you know that
they don't tell Tom haulin things they
don't give him scripts he thought that
they were there for a wedding when they
were doing the funeral scene but it's
interesting to know that they don't tell
the older more mature actors as
well who aren't known for giving away
big spoilers you think it'd be safe to
give Warmachine that information but I
don't think they give anybody any
scripts there and even Gwyneth Paltrow
isn't sure which Marvel movie she's been
in she just goes to set she films the
scenes there was that funny clip the
other day where she forgot that she was
in spider-man homecoming and Jon Favreau
had to remind her no you remember that
was for that first spider-man movie we
were actually doing it while we were
filming spider-man that was the first
time we just brought a film crew with us
down to Atlanta and we cooked at the
opposite well we were a Spider Man
together remember we're on spider-man we
weren't in spider-man yes we were all
coming you were in spider-man no yeah I
was in Avengers no avenge fighter man
also it's become remember especially at
the end and the end Tom Hollands there
and you're gonna walk out to a press
conference yes that was spider-man that
was spider-man but they've been
announcing a bunch of big comic-con
plans for the next couple of weeks so
it's taking place the third week in July
like it normally does so do the big base
for previews but there's also going to
be a bunch of other Marvel Hall H
comic-con panels the Russos are doing
their own Hall H panels separately in
the writers of Avengers endgame and
Avengers infinity war are also doing a
separate panel in Hall H by themselves
to Sony and DC are the two big studios
that aren't going so there's not gonna
be any really big spider-man stuff going
on outside of the Marvel Hall H
comic-con panel maybe if they have
spider-man 3 to announce they'll do it
during that but the only really big
previews and footage I expect them to
show off will be for the Black Widow
movie the probably announced the
Eternals movie shang-chi because they're
getting ready to cast those movies right
now and shoot them later
they're shooting Black Widow right now
though in maybe maybe outside chance
that they announced that they're
developing a Fantastic Four movie they
will save some of their secrets for the
Marvel d23 panel which is about a month
later in August but also do a separate
video for that for any big trailers that
they show up so no worries there's a
bunch of stuff happening this week they
just dropped a huge preview in a teaser
for The Witcher Netflix series I'll try
to get to that as fast as possible I
have a really cool Shazam black atom
deleted scene I'll post that probably
next tonight then my spider-man bar from
home post credit scene and Easter eggs
will start posting tomorrow there's so
much stuff that they set up for Marvel
phase 4 at the end of that be sure to go
see the movie as soon as possible
congratulations to Logan Sullivan you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details click here for that brand
new Avengers endgame post credits scene
for the Hulk and click here for that
Avengers endgame post credits scene for
spider-man thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]